ก็
สวัสดีค่ะบุรีรัมย์
สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 21 ค่ะผู้เดือน
อะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพศ.อะไรคะพ.ศ
a คศอะไรคะผช
2022 ค่ะอ่ะ
แต่ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะเนียนตอนนี้ 9 โมง 6
นาทีค่ะครูหญิง
09:06 ตอนเช้าเนาะใช่
ๆวันนี้ตื่นนอนบ่าเป็นยังไงคะอารมณ์ดีไหม
ทุเรียน
ตื่นนอนขึ้นมาก็ยังรู้สึก
ง่วงดิหน่อยค่ะผู้หญิง
แต่ว่าโอเคใช่มั้ย
อารมณ์ดีว่าโอเคนะแล้วก็ผู้หญิงนะคะตื่น
นอนมาแล้วเป็นยังไงบ้างวันนี้
วันนี้ไม่โอเคเลยครูเรียมแบบตื่นนอนปกติ
เนี่ยตื่นนอนเนี่ยเพราะว่าได้ยินเสียง
โทรศัพท์สมัยนาฬิกาปลุกที่จะดีๆแล้วก็
ตื่นอันนี้โอเคแต่วันนี้เนี่ยดูนาฬิกายัง
ไม่ปลุกแต่ได้ยินเสียงรถเต้นเสียงโลกคือ
เสียงดังแล้วก็ตื่นเถอะ
นิด
อารมณ์ไม่ดี
เพราะว่าเสียงดังมาก
นอนนอนอยู่ในห้องนอนแต่ได้ยินเสียงข้าง
นอกเข้ามาบางครั้งก็เป็นเสียงรถก็บี้แรร์
ซึ่งในบางทีพี่ขับรถแล้วก็อาจจะแบบ
ผู้เรียนไม่ได้ขุดหงิดเองจนตามจะไม่คะไม่
ค่ะรู้สึกว่าซึ่งคันคันจมูก
จะรู้จะเลย
ใกล้จากใช่ค่ะกูอ่ะแต่ผู้หญิงมันก็แค่วัน
เดียวเองนี่
ไม่ใช่ๆด้วยแค่แบบ
ก็แค่ตอนช่วงตื่นนอนเท่านั้นที่แบบว่าได้
ยินเสียงคนขับรถแล้วก็บางครั้งแล้วก็บีบ
แตรแบบไม่ใช่เบรค dot  Print  Print
Print
ๆแฮ่ครูเรียม RE
เสียง her
ยุคนี้หงุดหงิดใช่ไหมตอนนี้ยังหมดหงิด
อยู่ไหนดี
ตอนนี้หายแล้วจะมีไม่หงุดหงิดแล้วหายแล้ว
ก็เลยคิดว่าแบบในแต่ละวันเราเนี่ย
หงุดหงิดเรื่องอะไรบ้าง
เพราะว่าอย่าง
ถ้าเจอตัวจริงๆอ่ะแต่ละคนก็ไม่เหมือนกัน
ใช่ไหมคะครูเรียนบางคนก็หงุดหงิดง่ายๆบาง
คนก็ไม่ได้หงุดหงิดง่ายๆนะอย่างครูหญิง
น่ะ
เมื่อก่อนเป็นคนขี้หงุดหงิดไว้แต่พูดหยิบ
ง่ายๆอะไรนิดหน่อยก็โสด
อีกแล้วหงุดหงิดง่ายก่อนนะเมื่อก่อนแต่
ไม่ใช่โกรธใช่ไหมนี่ไม่ใช่แบบ
ไม่เข้าหมดเอ่อ
[เพลง]
ไม่เคยโกรธค่ะไม่โกรธก็จะแบบเหมือนเวลา
แบบเมื่อก่อนเวลาเราต้องได้ทำงานเนี่ยอาจ
อยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมก็ไม่ได้ขับรถไปทำงาน
ก็ขึ้นรถไฟฟ้า
BTS หรือว่า MRT บางครั้งเนี่ยอยู่บนรถ
ไฟฟ้าแล้วมีฝนมาอยู่ใกล้ๆสุดๆยืนอยู่บนรถ
ไฟฟ้าใช่ไหมคะเรารถไฟฟ้าก็มีที่ค่ะปีที่
ที่ที่
เยอะๆแต้มอีโคตรเนี่ยเดินเพราะก็มา
แล้วก็ไม่ยืนใกล้ๆแล้วก็บางทีมีแขนโดน
แล้ว
ทำไมโดนบนรถไฟสุดคนเดียวหยิบเยอะหรือ
เปล่า
ที่ไหนคนเยอะแต่ก็อีกขี้ไงมีที่แบบ Smooth
with  a หรือว่า Miss  A เดินมาตรงนี้ก็
ยืนได้ตรงนี้ยืนได้แต่ว่ายื่นใกล้แล้วก็
โดน Love หงุดหงิดเพราะว่าผู้หญิงไม่ใช่
บุตรหงิดแล้วใช่ๆ
ก็เงิน
เหมือนเรียมาเวลาที่อยู่กรุงเทพว่า
มันจะมีถนอมใช่ไหมถนนที่รถวิ่ง
อันเนี่ยถนน
เราก็จะมีฟุตบาทให้คนเดิน
ดินก็จะเดินเดินบนฟุตบาทมันจะมีสองข้าง
ทางบาดคนก็เดินได้แต่เวลาที่รถติดนิรถ
เยอะๆมีรถ
รถรถรถรถเยอะๆมอเตอร์ไซค์ก็ชอบขับรถมาบน
ฟุตบาท
นะวินมอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่ไหม
ใส่ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ขึ้นมา
จริงๆชุดบาทเนี่ยมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยขับบน
ฟุตบาทเนี่ยไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคะฟุตบาทเนี่ยให้
คนเดิน
ใช่เงียบก็เดินเดินอยู่แล้วเขาก็แบบขับมา
ก็ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์มา
แล้วลืมต้องเดินเดินกับหลบหลบมอเตอร์ไซค์
ให้มอเตอร์ไซค์วิ่ง
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงเคยเจอไหมคะทำไม
ผู้หญิงเคยเจอเหมือน
พูดเตรียมในแค่เจอมอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่ไหมผู้
หญิงเคยเจอกับว่าเราเนี่ยเดินอยู่บน
ฟุตบาทแล้วมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยขับมาบอย
ฟุตบาทแล้วก็บีบแตรไล่เรา
[เพลง]
เราเดินอยู่อย่างเงี้ยแล้วมอเตอร์ไซค์ผิด
สมัยว่าฟุตบาทเนี่ยไม่ใช่ทางของ
มอเตอร์ไซค์แต่มอเตอร์ไซค์แหนะขับก็มา
แล้วก็เดินเดินปกติจะพอมอเตอร์ไซค์ขับ
เข้ามาแล้วก็แบบเราเราเนี่ยไม่หลบ
มอเตอร์ไซค์
รถมอเตอร์ไซค์ก็คงแบบหงุดหงิดก็เลยบีบแตร
แบบบินแบบเราก็หงุดหงิดสมัคร
คุณต้องขับข้างล่างนะฟุตบาทเนี่ยคนเดินอะ
นะถ้าถ้ามอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่บีบแตรไล่เราวิ่ง
ก็ไม่หงุดหงิดนะ
คะแต่เราตั้งแต่มอเตอร์ไซค์ขึ้นมาบ้านน่ะ
ใช่
ๆแต่ว่าบนฟุตบาทเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนคือเราก็
เคยอ่ะเขาแล้วแหละเราก็เคยอาจจะทำให้คน
หงุดหงิด
และเราก็เคยหงุดหงิดคนที่เดินบนฟุตบาท
มันมีหลายเรื่องเลยนะแบบอย่างเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยคนไทยคิดว่าหลายๆคนเป็นเนาะถ้า
ชอบเล่นโทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมรถติดโทรศัพท์จะ
เล่นโทรศัพท์ตลอดเวลาแล้วเวลาที่เดินบน
ฟุตบาทเนี่ยก็เดินไปด้วยแล้วก็เล่น
โทรศัพท์ไปด้วยบางครั้งเนี่ยเราเนี่ยรีบ
สวยเรารีบแล้วก็คนก็เดินแบบช้าๆเดินเล่น
โทรศัพท์
แล้วผู้หญิงอยู่ข้างหลังใช่
แล้วเขาก็ไม่สนใจไงว่ามีใครเป็นอยู่หรือ
เปล่าเขาก็เดินช้าๆแล้วก็เล่นโทรศัพท์
แล้วเราก็เดินอยู่ข้างหลังแล้วก็
หงุดหงิด
ที่จริงอยู่กรุงเทพเนี่ย
ทำให้เราเป็นคนขี้หงุดหงิดเนาะใช่เขาบาง
ทีเราก็ดีดเนาะมีหลายหลายครั้งที่เรารู้
สึกที่
รีบไปจะรีบไปหาเพื่อนต้องเรียนรู้สึกว่า
คนอื่นๆที่เราเห็นทำไมเดินช้าจัง
ทำไมทำงานช้าจัง
เธอนะทำไมขับรถช้าจังแล้วเราก็จริงๆคนที่
คนที่ขับรถอ่ะคนที่ขับรถในกรุงเทพเนี่ย
ถ้าสมมติครูเรียมคุณเรียมยังไม่ได้ขับรถ
ดีกลุ่มอ่ะอุ่นเตรียมอยู่ไม่ได้มา
กรุงเทพฯผู้เรียนอาจจะแบบโอเคสบายสบายไม่
ได้เป็นคนขี้หงุดหงิดไม่ได้หงุดหงิดง่ายๆ
แล้วพ่อกูเลี้ยงมาอยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็ขับ
รถไม่น่าจะเปลี่ยนให้เราเป็นคนขี้
หงุดหงิดก็ได้เนาะกับเวลาเราเห็นคน
กรุงเทพฯขับรถอ่ะหรือว่าคนไทยขับรถอ่ะ
ใช่ๆไม่เคยเจอเต็มที่แบบมีรถที่กรุงเทพฯ
เยอะๆใช่ไหมแล้วเนี่ยตรงนี้ก็เป็นรถ
รถรถ
มีเรียมน่ะอยู่ตรงนี้
ขับรถอยู่ตรงนี้
แล้วมีรถอยู่ข้างหน้าอีกคันนึง
เวลาอยู่กรุงเทพฯเวลาจะออกจากซอยนะผู้
หญิงเขาร้องแบบทำไมอ่ะต้องกลับพุ่งออกไป
เลยแบบจะมารอรอให้รถผ่านไปผ่านไปผ่านไป
ให้มันมีแบบช่องว่างอย่างเงี้ยไม่ได้
หาอย่าเพิ่งคิดว่าคันนี้น่ะเพื่อนออกไปสิ
ออกไปออกไปเร็วๆทำไมแบบรอรอรอต้องขับออก
ไปเลยเดี๋ยวก็รออีกข้างทาง
ไหนใช่ก็เลยคิดแบบมาหลังจากที่อื่นหรือ
เปล่ามาจากขับรถมาจากอะไรนะ
แถวอาจารย์จังหวัดใช่ต่างจังหวัดที่ไม่
ใช่กรุงเทพฯ
ถ้าเกิดกรุงเทพฯไม่คิดว่าเดี๋ยวออกทันที
เหมือนคนขับรถกรุงเทพเหมือนเล่นเกมมาคะ
ว่าพอเห็นปุ๊ปว่าต้องเอาหัวเอาไปก่อนแล้ว
เพราะว่าเราจะรอให้รถที่วิ่งมาแบบคุย
เรียมบอกอ่ะแล้วก็ตลอดเลยก็เชิญข้าครับ
กรุงเทพฯไม่มีนะคะ
มีนะแต่น้อยมาก
เออ
ใช่คนกรุงเทพฯก็เลยแบบเวลาขับรถคนที่ขับ
รถในกรุงเทพฯบ่อยๆก็จะรู้สึกแบบต้องเร็วๆ
ก็มีคนช้าเราจะรออะไร
ออนไลน์ออกไปเสื่อมมีอะไรเออ
รู้สึกจริงๆหงุดหงิด
เออโทรหาแบบเวลาอยู่กรุงเทพฯเราจะได้ยิน
เสียงอ่าแปลรถคนรถอ่ะที่บีบแลรถบ่อยๆว่า
แบบบางครั้งเราอุดไงแต่มันพูดไม่ได้เลย
พูดแบบสวนทุเรียนน่ะกูเรียนรอเป็นคันที่ 2
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วคันหน้าเนี่ยไม่ไปซะทีนึงแต่
คุณเรียมก็เห็นว่านี่มันไปได้มันเลี้ยว
ออกจากซอยได้แต่รถคันหน้าไม่ไปคุยก็ปีน
บีนพินปีบแตร
คนขับรถเออใช่เดี๋ยวคนขับรถก็ผู้หญิงคิด
ว่าคนละแบบขับขันหน้าเวลาได้ยินเสียง
เรียงดิบแต่ละ
ก็รู้สึกว่าออกไปไม่ได้
ถึงใช่อยู่ตอนข้าทาส
ใช่ค่ะคิดว่าถ้าครูเรียมบีบครั้งแรกอ่ะ
เขาอาจจะไม่หงุดหงิดแต่กูเรียนแบบบินบิน
บิน
บ่อยๆเขาก็จะหงุดหงิดเหมือนกันแล้วก็ลงมา
แล้วก็ทะเลาะกันใช่ไหมคะเวลาหงุดหงิดลงมา
แบบถ้าเกิดพูดไม่ดีไม่ดีอาจจะแบบกลายเป็น
เปลี่ยนเป็นโปรด
โหลดแล้วก็ชกต่อยกันการ
ใส่แต่ว่าหงุดหงิดก็ยังไม่ถึงกับโกรธนะ
ๆคิดว่าแบบว่าถ้าขับรถอย่างผู้หญิงน่ะไม่
ขับรถจะไม่ขับรถในกรุงเทพฯแต่
เวลาที่เรานั่งรถฟู้ดแล้วนั่ง Grab นั่ง
รถแท็กซี่ก็อาจกลับบ้านอย่างนี้ค่ะแล้ว
เราเห็นแบบเครื่องมันจะเรียกยังไงเหมือน
เหมือนแบบว่าๆอย่างบ้านเราใช่ไหมคะ
อันเนี้ยรู้สึกหงุดหงิดหงุดหงิดมากๆอ่ะ
8 กันอย่างนะคะ
ถ้าสมมติว่าก่อนอื่นเนี้ย
นี้มันเป็นแบบถนนน่ะแล้วตรงนี้เป็น
อพาร์ทเม้นท์ใช่ไหมคะอพาร์ทเม้นของเราอ่ะ
แล้วตอนนี้มันจะมีทางเข้าใช่ไหมทางเข้า
ทางเข้าพาร์ทเม้นท์และเวลาทำงานตรงนี้ค่ะ
มันก็จะมี
จะมีเครื่องหมายเนี้ยที่แบบห้ามจอดเวลารถ
เวลารถมาอ่ะใช่มั้ยแล้วก็จะเว้นช่องเอา
ไว้ให้รถจากคอนโดเนี่ยออกหรือว่าเข้า
อ๋อใช่ๆเท่ป่ะใช่ค่ะแล้วแถวบ้านครูหญิง
อ่ะก็คือถ้ารถฝั่งเนี้ยฝั่งมารมาจากเนี้ย
มันจะติดมันจะติดบ้าๆแบบนี้ก็คือไปตรงนี้
จะเป็น BTS อันนี้ไม่มี GS แต่เวลาผู้
หญิงมาจากครั้งนี้
มันจะไม่ติดรถเนี่ยมันจะไม่ติดใช่ไหมคะ
แต่พอมาถึงอ่ะ
บางทีอ่ะรถต้องจอดอยู่ตรงนี้เลี้ยวเข้า
ไม่ได้เลี้ยวเข้าบ้านเนี่ยไม่ได้เพราะว่า
ว่ามันจะมีรถ 1 คันที่ไม่สนใจป้ายอะไร
ทั้งนั้นจอดอยู่ที่นี่
มีรถที่จอดอยู่ตรงเนี้ยแล้วแบบเรื่องรถก็
ติดกับรถติดขยับไม่ได้แตกผู้หญิงฝั่ง
เนี้ยรถไม่ติดนะโอเคแต่เราเนี่ยเลี้ยว
เด็กชายวัชรู้สึกว่ะหงุดหงิดมากแล้วเมื่อ
เห็นหรอ
ไม่เห็นป้ายนี้หรอว่าห้ามจอด
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมไม่มองคือเขารีบไปไหนเลย
เขาเนี่ยจะมีรถ
สวยมีรถเนี่ยเขารีบอยู่ที่นี่แต่ที่นี่ก็
คือโตเมติกรถติด
ทำให้คนอื่นเนี่ยรถติดเพราะว่าคันนี้มัน
เลี้ยวไม่ได้แผนที่ออกจากคอนโดก็เลี้ยว
ออกไม่ได้ก็เราก็รู้สึกหงุดหงิดมากเวลาคน
ที่ขับรถแล้วไม่ดูไม่รู้ป้ายไม่รู้ถนน
หรือว่าขับรถในกรุงเทพฯเลี้ยวซ้ายมันจะ
เลี้ยงตลอดไม่ใช่ไหมคะเดี๋ยวซ้ายเนี่ย
ผ่านตลอดแต่มาทำเนี่ยตรงตรงนะไม่เลี้ยว
แต่อยู่ Rain เลี้ยวซ้ายตั้งรู้สึกแบบ
ส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นรถเมล์นะคะรถเมล์จะขึ้นใจ
ว่าว่า
ขนาดเราเขาเขาชอบอยู่ทางซ้ายเพราะว่าถ้า
เกิดเขาเห็นคนที่อยากจะขึ้นรถเมล์เขาก็จะ
ได้จอดจอดจอดเข้าเลยเหรอขับอยู่ทางซ้าย
ตลอด
ได้แล้วก็แบบทางสไตล์มันเลี้ยวซ้ายตลอดนะ
คะมันจะเร็วมันจะเร็วเขาก็จะขับแล้วก็
เจาะส่วนลดคันข้างหลังที่จะเลี้ยวซ้ายก็
เลี้ยวไม่ได้เพราะว่ามีคะเนี้ยที่ตรงจอด
อยู่แล้วก็รู้สึกว่านี่ขนาดเราเนาะไม่ได้
เป็นคนขับรถ
เรายังรู้สึกหงุดหงิดเลยอ่ะแบบเวลาขับรถ n
คนขับรถในกรุงเทพฯได้กินว่า
หน้าที่ขับรถในกรุงเทพฯคนถ้าจะเป็นคนนี้
ว่าจะกัดคนธรรมดาใจเย็นก็เปลี่ยนเป็นคน
ขี้หงุดหงิดผู้หญิงถ้าเป็นคนขี้หงุดหงิด
อยู่แล้วแล้วขับรถคิดว่าได้ทะเลาะกับคน
แน่ๆเลยค่ะเพราะว่าหงุดหงิดหงุดหงิดมากๆ
ก็จะเหมือนครูเรียมบ่สมัยมันจะโกรธหรือ
ไม่ไหวแล้ว
แต่ว่าคนอาจจะแบบรุ่นหงุดหงิดมากๆจนรู้
ว่า
ไม่หงุดหงิดดีกว่าไปๆ
หงุดหงิดวันที่แล้วเหนื่อยเหนื่อยมากพอ
แล้ว
จริงๆหงุดหงิดแล้วเหนื่อยมากเลยนะแบบเรา
ปล่อยจนถึงเหมือนเป็นผู้หญิงว่าเมื่อก่อน
เป็นคนขี้หงุดหงิดไงขึ้นรถไฟฟ้าเดินอยู่
ที่ฟุตบาทอะไรนิดหน่อยก็เธอ
แต่ละหงุดหงิดบ่อยๆแต่ตอนนี้ใช่มั้ย
เหมือนเราดีขึ้นโตขึ้นเราก็จะรู้สึกแบบก็
น่ารักเหมือนทุเรียนพูดหงุดหงิดแล้วมัน
เหนื่อยก็ไม่เป็นไรโอเค
ใช่
ไม่หงุดหงิดดีกว่า
เมื่อก่อนเราเป็นเด็กๆเราเป็นเด็กๆอะไร
นิดหน่อยก็หงุดหงิดเนอะเออ
ไปตอนนี้ก็แบบว่าโอเคไม่เป็นไรนะคะก็ไม่
รู้เหมือนกันว่านักเรียนอยู่ประเทศไทยมา
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเวลานักเรียนเห็นคุณไก่ขับ
รถหรือว่าคนไทยเดินที่ฟุตบาทหรือเหมือน
คู่เรียงใช่ไหมเห็นมอเตอร์ไซค์ขี่บน
ฟุตบาทนักเรียนเนี่ยหงุดหงิดไหม
นักเรียนหงุดหงิดไหมค่ะ
ใช่ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะใช่ค่ะแต่ว่า
วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะคุย
ใจเราสองคนก็ก็ต้องไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเดี๋ยว
เจอกันใหม่
วีดีโอนะคะใช่ค่ะต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครู
หญิง
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนในบ้าง
บายน